in 1992 novelist neil stephenson wrote a
novel titled snow crash
it was set in a dystopian future world
in which humans interacted with each
other via avatars in a 3d virtual world
they made cities had their own virtual
currency and humans chose to live in the
virtual world rather than the real one
often confusing one with the other
well that pretty much sums up metaverse
hello and welcome to med simplified i'm
dr umar malik and i'm back today with
another interesting video
metaverse
everyone and everything related to
metaverse is hot news today
metaverse is also becoming really
popular it's being called the next
frontier of the internet itself
the grayscale report says that it's
worth over one trillion dollars in
annual revenue which makes it a pretty
big opportunity for anyone willing to
bet on it now you might be wondering why
we med simplified decided to make a
video on it
the answer will surprise you
now before we move forward let me take a
moment here to thank our sponsor for
this video which is data camp
data camp is an online learning platform
where you can learn anything regarding
coding programming data analysis and
much more in small easy to digest
bite-sized courses datacamp allows you
to learn data skills at your own pace in
the comfort of your own home
datacamp has over 350 courses which are
designed by top experts in the field
that can benefit everyone from beginners
to pros datacamp also provides
certificates for the courses which you
can add in your resume
these skills are high in demand in
today's technology driven world and can
add a significant positive impact in
your resume
unlock new career opportunities and
become data fluent today
use my link in the description box below
and check out the first chapter of any
data camp course for free
so coming back to the topic at hand let
me just simplify what metaverse is
well one expert says that the metaverse
is a digital universe where users can
live and interact with each other much
like the novel snow crash i told you
about but the real metaverse goes beyond
that
metaverse has various elements that
include blockchain technology augmented
reality virtual reality and game theory
metaverse allows for trustless
transactions and unbeatable ownership of
assets although it's all online and
virtual
okay well i just used some big terms
which may confuse you and the true tech
and the expertise behind metaverse is
far from this video's prospect so
keeping that in mind i'll tell you some
aspects of the metaverse which will
affect your health and the way we see
the future of the health industry
so let's begin
now before covid began ever since the
beginning of medical science healthcare
meant physical interaction between the
patients and the doctors
so to get diagnosed to get operated or
get treated the whole process was
hands-on
this changed slightly postcovid
more people chose teleconsultations and
home-based health care over potentially
contracting covid at dedicated health
institutions
metaverse seeks to potentially
revolutionize this forever
let's take a few examples
number one meta
meta or previously known as facebook
group acquired oculus vr technology in
2014
in 2012 to 2014 the oculus virtual
reality headset was a thing of awe
tech enthusiasts worldwide were
impressed by its immersive experience of
the virtual world and its endless
possibilities
well since its acquisition by the meta
group oculus has grown beyond its
enthusiast demography into the
healthcare industry one of its most
notable collaborations was with the who
academy
during the ongoing covid19 pandemic a
mobile app was developed which helped
healthcare workers develop skills for
more efficient management of covid19
patients using virtual reality
vr allowed for simulation of potential
situations
such as how to wear a ppe kit and how to
discard a ppe kit
the app was available in multiple
languages the technology offered by
oculus is also revolutionizing the way
surgeons operate
at the university of connecticut the
orthopedic surgical residents are taught
various procedures using the vr headsets
this allows the surgical students to
perfect their skills while using the
advantage of a 3d vr environment
additionally they had access to a
plethora of surgical scenarios at their
disposal and they were ready for any
orthopedic emergency
number two microsoft
another mega company who is actively
investing into the expansion of
metaverse healthcare is microsoft
since their emergence microsoft is well
known for their software expertise and
their universal presence
and they are still excelling in that
sector
they introduced mesh
now mesh is a cloud-based online
platform it allows people in different
physical locations to join the digital
metaverse
this is via its ability to integrate 3d
experiences on various devices
this means it can be used through mobile
phones laptops headsets and vr capable
machines together
take for example a group of medical
students worldwide having joined the
same virtual space
they can go through 3d model of the
human body and study it layer by layer
on specially designed vr modules
one way this is possible is by their
product hololens which is also a vr
based product and allows for immersive
3d experience
this product also has some real life
applications
a company called striker which
specializes in designing and
construction of operating rooms uses a
hololens-based device
this allows them to standardize their
designs
also they can tackle any physical issues
by visualizing potential complications
and making the necessary adjustments in
real time
another indiana based medical device
company zimmer biomet is also using the
hololens it uses this tech to build
surgical instruments collect patient
data and share the experience with the
other medical professionals to increase
patient safety
number three increase in the usage of
augmented reality and virtual reality
tech
at john hopkins institute the department
of neurosurgery has incorporated vr tech
into their patient care and teaching
program
using ar headsets made by an israeli
company called augmetics they are using
ar to understand the intricacies of the
body
the headset has an eye display that
projects images of a patient's internal
anatomy such as bones and other tissue
while the person operates
using this they performed the first ar
surgeries ever
they used ct and mri scans to build 3d
models of the patient's brain and the
spine
before the required surgeries they
navigate through the various
complications they might face on their
way and plan a precise route
they successfully removed a cancerous
tumor from a patient's spine using ar
at university of miami they have a
special gordon center for simulation and
innovation in medical education
they are specializing in using ar and vr
techniques
recently they've started emergency
scenario management courses to train
health care workers
this is to help them respond better to
situations which require immediate care
such as stroke heart attack and
irregular heartbeat
dr barry isenberg the director of gordon
center says that the virtual world
relieves us of physical boundaries it
guarantees all the learners have an
equal opportunity to learn despite their
distance by letting everyone be
virtually present at an emergency scene
brave mind is another way vr is helping
patients worldwide
ptsd or post-traumatic stress disorder
which affects millions of people every
year it occurs after a person undergoes
a highly traumatic event and is unable
to deal with it mentally
brave mind is one of the new innovations
used by health care professionals to
help ex-military ptsd patients
it allows the patient to experience the
traumatic experience of the battlefield
in a safe environment and eventually let
go of what happened
this technique is available in various
veterans administration hospitals where
it has been shown to produce meaningful
results
if you would like to know more about
ptsd stay tuned we're going to upload a
video on this topic soon
now i'm not saying that the future of
healthcare is metaverse oriented
we never for once thought that we could
teach robots to operate on humans but
that became a reality in the past decade
itself
we never thought we could see the inside
of the brain but we now can do so by
using 3d models
such examples are endless but the future
holds great prospect revolution is
expected
so if you like this video share this
with your friends and your family if
you're new to our channel consider
subscribing if you like our content we
at med simplified always appreciate your
support and feedback consider becoming a
member of our youtube channel or patreon
community
you can find us on instagram search for
med simplified we post daily facts
medical tidbits and posts that will
brighten your day
the links are in the description below
as always take care and i'll see you in
the next one